Maybe for you there's a tomorrow,
but for some of us, there's only today.
Hey sexy, get in!
Hi. No I'm eating, get out.
Aw, you guys.
Big party tonight,
my mom's going out of town.
Oh my god.
What's she doing here?
Watch this
Psycho.
What are you doing?
What happened last night?
What are you talking about?
I've been having déja-vu all day long.
Are you okay?
It was't a dream. It really happened,
again.
The only way to escape,
is to change.
Watch out for the truck,
What truck?
I had to do something that would make a difference.
Maybe things could change...
And maybe I could change them.
It's too late,
it's never too late.
Are you in trouble?
You can trust me,
you can trust me back.
Maybe for you there's a tomorrow,
but for some of us, there's only today.
But I didn't know any of that
until right before I fell.